ولان النيجر يتعرض لتهديد بالتدخل تزداد
ملامحه وضوحا ويعد له من دوله مجاوره فان
مجالنا الجوي مغلق اعتبار من الاحد السادس
من اغسطس والى اشعار اخر وان اي محاوله
الانتهاكه ستقابل برد فوري وحازم
[موسيقى]
غرفه اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم
تعقد اجتماع قمه في ابوجا الخامس المقبل
لبحث الموقف بين انقلاب النيجر وقاده
الانقلاب يغلقون المجال الجوي
ويتوعدون برد قوي وفوري على اي محاوله
لخرقه فرنسا تعلق رحلاتها لمالي وبوركينا
فاسو وترفع سقف تحذيراتها لمواطنيها
الباقينا في النيجر في حين تدعو ايطاليا
لتمديد مهله اكواس وتلوح المانيا
بالعقوبات
واشنطن تقول ان تعزيز قوتها في الشرق
الاوسط بثلاثه الاف جندي ياتي لتخفيف
التوترات الناجمه عن مضايقات ايران
ومصادره السفن وطهران تؤكد ان ان المنطقه
يتحقق عبر تعاون دولها وترفض اي تدخل
خارجي في امور تتعلق بالامن
روسيا تقول انها اسقطت مسيرتين في مقاطعتي
كالوجا وبالجورود واوكرانيا تعلن مقتل
ثلاثه في قصف روسي بخار كيب وخرسون وتقول
ان الهجمات الروسيه تتركز على المناطق
الشرقيه والبحريه الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن
ثلاث سفن روسيه معاديه تجوب البحر الاسود
قوات الاحتلال تقتحم حي المراح والضاحيه
الشرقيه من مدينه جنين بالضفه الغربيه بعد
ساعات من اغتيالها لثلاثه شبان من كتيبه
جنين حيث تصدى لها مقاومنا فلسطينيون
بينما اقتحمت قوه الاحتلال عددا من
المنازل بذريعه ملاحقه مطلوبين حسب
تعبيرها واعتقلت شخصين قبل ان تنسحب من
المدينه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]